ken um oh you're actually one of the few
people we had in the first tournament so
welcome back attack me if you dare I
will crush you it's great to see you
again
good seeing you again I don't know if
anyone told you but we are we are
actually trying to do things a little
bit different this year um each fighter
actually costs my side of things about
$52,000 that's quite a bit of overhead
so it suffice it to say we are looking
for a very diverse group of fighters to
justify that cost all right so to be
frank you are exactly like Ryu and you
are unnecessary what you're exactly like
Ryu and you're completely unnecessary no
but what I don't get working on this how
are you different from rally what are
your moves okay
fireball Oh dragon uppercut yeah and the
hurricane yeah Ryu does it
Ryu does it and Ryu does it we got it
people come to see a hurricane kick we
got a guy that does a hurricane care I
think people would want to see two
hurricane kicks I am so sorry Ken I'm
gonna have to deny your applicant wait
okay look I have red clothes you wear a
red guy I wear red gay that's the top of
the list of what makes you different
from Ryu is that your red yeah and when
I kick someone it'll look red when you
kick someone it'll look red that's what
you're saying yeah oh it's a no no no
wait wait wait I'm different than Ryu oh
yeah I'm blonde you're blonde and
redundant come on man
Ryu wears a headband and you I don't
wear it while you're out there doing the
exact same moves yes no God you tricky
man to be frank ken there's no way I'm
filling out another pile of paperwork
just to let in a blonde headband less
red Ryu it's enough wait wait wait wait
what if I wear blue
cool I'm glad you get it your
application is denied but you know to be
honest this is quite a relief for me as
a fan of the tournament if I see another
fight we're dry Ewan can just throwing
fireballs at each other and lessly in
there proofing and which one's gonna get
them first and everybody's bored for 99
seconds I'm gonna ship I will [ __ ] you
look like meg Ryan